wenn jetzt mal wählen würde hallo hier
ist alex alles cool
das klappt jetzt willkommen bei anderen
video und zwar habe ich mir für euch
überlegt immer wenn ich irgendwas
gepostet von wegen ja was wollt ihr
video demnächst sehen dann kamen einmal
grund hat macht nochmal feldkreuz
verkäufer oder vielleicht wenders oder
doch vielleicht wenn calls oder auch
zwischendurch mal wahl oder wahrheit
oder pflicht heißt glaube ich dass kann
ich vielleicht auch machen aber ich habe
mich heute für dieses fan call video
entschieden weil ich da bock drauf hab
ich habe mir ein paar nummern von euch
zuschicken lassen im farbigen über die
zeit bald so bekommen von wem kannst du
bitte anrufen und so und ja ich würde
sagen wir fangen direkt mal an so uns
habe ich mir als erstes die nina
ausgesucht die hat mir ganz auf ihre
nummer geschrieben und da hab ich
gedacht ja komm ruft man also wir rufen
jetzt nina anja ich habe die nummer
jetzt mal ein geben ich hoffe das ist
die richtige wenn ich dann werden wir
das gleich merken
auf jeden fall überlegen jetzt einfach
mal ja ich nehme jetzt einfach mal den
namen jonas und fragt sie warum sie so
viel mist dem jonas über mich erzählt
also die erste verrate ich jetzt mal die
zweite durchgang ganz normal hallo und
ich machte sein kann man so vielleicht
hat dann hat man eine stimme nicht ganz
so doll
ja hier ist der benedikt ich wollte mal
wissen warum zudem gegen dem dem jonas
so viel mist über mich erzählt genau dem
jonas ja denkt doch mal selber nach
kennst du kein jonas also weiß ich nicht
will überlege ich gerade kannst du auch
einen ende heißt du nicht auf instagram
crazy nina oder so ja ich bin gut ne du
hast bestimmt so 20 mal da nur geschickt
ich dachte kein alex dachte ich dass du
kennst kein alex gesagt hier ist
benedikt ein bisschen was ist los
kein problem gerne äußerlich und du bist
jetzt die ersten anrufe aber hätten
schon vollkommen gar nicht muss ich bin
fast die stimme nicht erkannt ist
irgendwann grüßen oder so weil du bist
jetzt im video
alles klar die gucken das video dann
auch ich musste mir jetzt ein bisschen
die nächsten anruf bei unserer gespräche
gehen das schon fast fünf minuten und
nachher das video so lange alles klar
reifen die auch beim taxi ja das war ja
ganz angenehm
jetzt gucken wir mal noch so anrufen
können ich habe mir da ein paar
aufgeschrieben
okay ich habe es jetzt bei fünf leuten
versucht die sind alle nicht
reingegangen ich habe jetzt gerade noch
zwei nummern auf install umkommen vor
fünf minuten oder so und die müssen
jetzt einfach dran gehen wenn nicht dann
weiß ich auch nicht ich glaube dann
lasse ich das einfach und macht für
morgen gar kein video nur wenig so das
ist jetzt die annika und ii muss einfach
da rangehen sagt einfach direkt als ich
alex bin und dass ich es cool finde dass
sie mir jetzt grad voraus sind sie dran
wenn jetzt mal wählen würde hallo hier
ist alex alles cool
ja ich pass mal auf ich habe jetzt
gerade fünf leute angerufen und sie sind
alle nicht rangegangen
das habe ich heute gesehen dass du mir
deine nummer geschickt hast und du musst
dir eigentlich rein gehen wenn du mir
die vor zwei minuten erst geschickt hast
das ist das aber cool
freust du dich denn wenigstens wissen
willst du irgendwann grüßen vielleicht
oder willst mit irgendwas fragen keine
ahnung wie heißt denn leni dann auch bei
mir schöne grüße an dich linie und hast
du eine frage oder so nicht stimmt
klappt so weil es echt komisch wenn du
fünf leute anruft und keiner dran geht
bis hin zum normalerweise durch den
video so eine halbe stunde setzte hier
schon eine stunde
brauchst du nicht du nur wenn du jetzt
keine frage machst du da doch irgendwas
sagen willst ich würde mich freuen wenn
das jetzt okay ist dann kann ich direkt
noch ein paar weitere leute anrufen und
dass du jetzt ich glaube du wolltest
physik lernen oder so eine habe ich
gelesen und ich gucke dann jetzt mal
wenig noch zu anrufen kann und
vielleicht wäre dann auch mal dran geht
alles klar
ciao hoffe sehr cool und jetzt habe ich
wenigstens wieder ein bisschen
motivation geschöpft noch wenig anders
anzurufen weil sonst würde ich jetzt
aufhören wenn die auch nicht reingehen
würde egal wir gucken mal wenn wir noch
so anhören könnt ja dann haben wir jetzt
noch die anita und ich auch noch mal
dran ich tue jetzt wirklich mal so auf
den weil die haben ihre nummer gestern
geschickt dass ich einfach nur hallo
sagen und sie ihr rad muss welt bin
hallo hallo weiß ich nicht das meiste ja
ganz sicher was richtig geraten ist
irgendwas wird irgendwas sagen oder eine
frage oder irgendwann grüßen zu sie die
heißt ja genauso wie meine freundin ja
ja ich weiß
dankeschön na gut dann gucke jetzt noch
ob ich noch mein anrufe und habe mich
gefreut
gut das war jetzt auch sehr entspannt
und ich würd mal sagen das video ist
jetzt bestimmt schon bei sechs oder
sieben minuten weil die gespräche
einfach so lange dauern
und ja wenn ihr bock habt dass ich
vielleicht einen zweiten teil daraus
machen lasst einfach den daumen nach
oben da dann weiß ich bescheid wird mich
auf jeden fall sehr freuen also wenn ihr
bock habt dass ich vielleicht euch dann
auch mal anrufen
ihr könnt eure normalen einfach auf
facebook schreiben der link dazu ist
natürlich unten in der video
beschreibung hier ist noch twitter und
instagram eingemeindet könnte er auch
abdecken und hier auf der
gleich geht es weiter mit meinem letzten
video das war so ein kleiner tag würde
mich freuen wenn ihr euch den mal
anschaut und hier auf der anderen seite
im klatschen war einfach mal irgendein
anderes video rein lasst euch
überraschen
ich würde sagen wir sehen uns am
nächsten samstag wieder und schönes
wochenende noch drei leute